On ne sait jamais.
Non, non,
on ne sait jamais.
(Applaudissements et cris)
Merci.
J'ai récemment eu la chance unique de chercher de l'or
dans l'immense mine de chansons produites par Chess Records,
un label basé à Chicago très actif dans les années 50 et 60 aux États-Unis
et cette musique a été diffusée à travers le monde.
Les chansons que je chante ce soir
sont tirées d'un album que je viens de sortir qui s'appelle « Playing Chess »
et qui rend hommage à ces chansons.
Ces gens étaient les innovateurs du rock 'n' roll, de la soul et du R&B
tels que nous les connaissons.
(Applaudissements)
(Musique)
(Chantant) Au-delà de la montagne,
au-delà de la mer,
il y a une fille qui attend,
elle attend,
elle m'attend.
(Musique)
Au-delà de la rivière,
au-delà de tous les nuages,
elle est au-delà du vent qui souffle fort.
Au-delà de la montagne,
une fille m'attend.
(Musique)
Dites au sable,
à chaque brin d'herbe,
s'il vous plaît, dites au vent de laisser passer mon amour.
Au-delà de la montagne,
une fille m'attend.
Dites à la lune là-haut --
là-haut dans le ciel.
Dites à tous les oiseaux qui passent en volant
qu'au-delà et au-delà de la montagne...
mon amour m'attend.
Oh,
au fond de chaque nuit noire et étoilée,
oh, quel mystère
si bien scellé.
Au-delà de la montagne,
une fille m'attend.
Dites à la lune là-haut --
là-haut dans le ciel.
Dites aux oiseaux qui passent en volant
qu'au-delà et au-delà de la montagne
mon amour m'attend.
Au fond de chaque nuit noire et étoilée,
oh, quel mystère
si bien scellé.
Au-delà des montagnes,
une fille m'attend.
Elle m'attend.
Oh, elle m'attend.
Je sais, je sais, je sais, je sais, je sais.
Oh,
je sais, je sais, je sais, je sais, je sais.
je sais, je sais, je sais, je sais, je sais,
oh oh, oh.
(Applaudissements)